[Musique]
on termine ce journal avec le coup de
coeur culture du mardi bonsoir mélanie
pauli votre coup de coeur cette semaine
et musical on se rend dans un festival
avec vous mélangez tout à fait grégory
on verra au festival de saint germain en
laye alors ça se passe du 21 septembre
au 6 octobre
et ce ne sont pas moins de 33 artistes
qui répondent présents il ya bénabar
christophe laurent voulzy noah nolwenn
leroy bien sûr c'est dur de citer tout
le monde vers le festival a peut-être
plus de 30 ans mais cette année c'est
aussi un anniversaire c'est celui des
vitrines découvertes ont fait découvrir
des jeunes vers type b navarre et
d'autres sont passés par l'estival dans
les découvertes et donc là cette année
les ce sont les 10 ans des vitrines
découverte dans leur formule nationale
et internationale puisque on fera
découvrir le 22 fait prendre après midi
cet artiste qui viennent de belgique 1
du canada de suisse et de france
on a vu mélanie les visages de ces sept
artistes francophones en écoutant le
directeur de l'estival qui sont ils ces
artistes alors il ya trois représentants
français allaient ce qui a sorti son
premier ep en 2017
on a aussi beauty and the beast qui joue
la carte old school en mai l'ong du
blues du folk du swing ou encore john
milo en nos voisins suisses et belges
sont représentés par les fils du facteur
et yvan tirtiaux et les deux derniers
ont traversé l'atlantique
émile bilodeau et chandails pelouse
viennent du canada trente trois artistes
ou groupes difficile de faire son choix
parmi cette offre mais l'année ce que
vous nous ont conseillés un ou une
alors moi je vais plutôt me fier aux
directeurs du festival parce qu'il m'a
cité un artiste à plusieurs reprises
lors de notre entretien
et il s'agit de loïc lantoine il sera
accompagné du very big expirmé
expérimental to be free orchestra c'est
une association qui est né d'une
rencontre entre un poète à la voix
rocailleuse et un orchestre de 18
musiciens écouter
courts et très très vite après le
premier cheveu blanc est la plus belle
part
quand tout à coup et j'ai retourné la
première fois que je les ai vus père
était grand
la deuxième fois que je les goûts
et est immense
je vais pas fouiller que chez moi
et après
et si je taurine main qui tremble
quand même je pense quand même
je pense quand même je danse dans même
je tente ils se produiront le 22
septembre au théâtre du vésinet
l'estival hui débute le 21 septembre
avec un concert gratuit d'amélie de
catherine lara et cette 31e édition est
aussi dédié à l'association autour des
williams qui se bat grégory contre une
maladie génétique le syndrome de
williams et belle initiative merci
mélanie pour cette chronique on vous
retrouve dans un instant avec un nouveau
numéro de votre émission le 7-8 culture